Bienvenidos a esta emisión especial
dedicada a la guerra informativa en el
marco de la invasión rusa de Ucrania en
la que contrastaremos la comunicación
política entre vuelo de inmersalensky y
Vladimir Putin los líderes de dos países
enfrentados en un conflicto que no se
entendería sin el apoyo de la otan por
eso abordaremos el discurso mediático
occidental en momentos clave de estos 10
meses de una guerra que recuerda el
siglo XX pero que se disputa él era de
internet y las redes sociales
la invasión rusa de Ucrania empezó el 24
de febrero de 2022 Sin embargo cada uno
de los bandos Establece en un punto
distinto de la historia el inicio de
este conflicto la Guerra de Ucrania es
también una guerra de relatos
y hemos visto Quién es el único que
quiere la guerra
la falta de decisión de los países
occidentales y la guerra continua del
régimen de kiev contra su propio pueblo
no nos dejó más opción que lanzar una
operación militar especial para proteger
a los rusos y eliminar las amenazas a
nuestra seguridad que la otan ha creado
sistemáticamente en territorio ucraniano
Ucrania ha mostrado fortaleza en el
campo de batalla utilizando su derecho a
la legítima defensa de acuerdo con el
artículo 51 de la carta de la ONU
la operación se lleva a cabo en
cumplimiento de los tratados de amistad
cooperación y asistencia mutua entre
Rusia y estas repúblicas sobre la base
del artículo 51 de la carta de Naciones
Unidas
dos narrativas los actores principales
de esta guerra el presidente Ruso y el
ucraniano son dos Polos opuestos no solo
en el campo de batalla también en la
escena precisamente el contraste entre
el traje impoluto y la camiseta militar
entre el Palacio Imperial y el búnker de
guerra marcan inequívocamente dos formas
de comunicar la guerra
Vladimir ex agente de la kgb rostro
imperturbable Desde la distancia lanza
su operación militar especial para
desgasificar Ucrania
actor profesional cambia el traje por el
uniforme de guerra y prometo a su pueblo
permanecer en kiev hasta la victoria
acechado por los misiles de Moscú
convierte el Palacio presidencial en un
fuerte militar y en un plató
[Música]
desde donde cada noche Llama a Ucrania a
resistir
[Música]
honores pero no concede un funeral de
estado a gorbachó la Encarnación de la
decadencia soviética
solo baja de su pedestal para pedir a
las madres de los soldados rusos que no
crean las mentiras de Ucrania y para
visitar a los héroes heridos en su
misión de devolver la grandeza Rusia
aislado sin el apoyo explícito de sus
aliados defiende el éxito de su
operación en la plaza Roja de Moscú
[Música]
los líderes occidentales no paran de
visitar kiev selanski no abandona
Ucrania desde que empezó la guerra pero
sin dejar su país se dirige al mundo
entero
miembros del Congreso tengo el enorme
privilegio y el gran honor de
presentarles al presidente de Ucrania
bolodinski
Gloria Ucrania
una gira necesaria para un apoyo
imprescindible para Ucrania
[Aplausos]
Rusia y Ucrania son los dos ejércitos
enfrentados pero esta guerra no se
entiende Si la alianza entre occidente y
kiev y precisamente desde el inicio de
la invasión rusa cada uno de los bloques
ha intentado censurar la narrativa del
enemigo prohibiendo la presencia de
ciertos medios de comunicación en sus
territorios
ninguna gran nación puede existir Sin
Control sobre la información
Sí Rosa siguiendo esta línea de
pensamiento expresada por la redactora
jefe de RT el kremlin impulsó una nueva
ley de control de la información en la
que se prohíbe usar la palabra guerra
para referirse a la invasión rusa a
Ucrania y castiga con hasta 15 años de
prisión lo que pueda interpretarse como
ofensas contra el ejército de Rusia
una ley que precisamente motivó el
exilio o el cese de operaciones de
decenas de medios internacionales o
también de medios independientes rusos
guerra en Ucrania Putin ataca desafío
geopolítico el retorno de la historia o
lo impensable son algunos de los
titulares que recogieron la conmoción
occidental cuando se materializó La
amenaza de la invasión rusa el pasado 24
de febrero desde entonces los medios de
comunicación occidentales se han volcado
con Ucrania han denunciado la masacre de
civiles han defendido el apoyo de la
otan en forma de ayuda militar y de
ayuda económica buen investigado
crímenes de guerra un caso paradigmático
fue el bombardeo ruso de un hospital
materno infantil en Mario Paul el 9 de
marzo en ese momento la agencia
estadounidense
era el único medio internacional
presente en la asediada ciudad portuaria
y documentó el ataque contra civiles con
unas imágenes que escandalizaron al
mundo y que el kremlin a raíz de eso
respondió con dos líneas a discursivas
contundentes Sí Rosa la primera era que
el hospital estaba o sea era un refugio
del Comando neonazi azov y la segunda es
que las imágenes de eran un montaje de
occidente sin embargo el bombardeo fue
verificado por múltiples Fuentes
independientes y en agosto la
organización amnistía internacional sin
referencia explícita ese caso señaló que
las tácticas de combate de Ucrania ponen
en peligro a sus civiles al situar bases
militares en áreas residenciales un
informe marca que generó tanta polémica
e indignación en Ucrania y en cerdos
sectores de occidente que forzaron a la
organización a aclarar su comentario y a
insistir en que nada justifica la en
rusa si Rosa y además diez meses después
de una Guerra Relámpago que no fue
Ucrania Avanza en su contraofensiva
Europa sufre una crisis energética
derivada de las sanciones a Moscú sin
embargo occidente sigue reforzando esa
Alianza con kiev y además también lo
hacen sus medios de comunicación El
ejemplo más reduzcante de esto y quizás
el más paradigmático es quizás cuando la
revista Time Hace unos días nombró
afrodimir selenski como persona del año
no como dijo el director jefe de esta
revista estadounidense su ofensiva
informativa cambió el clima del sistema
geopolítico desencadenando una oleada de
acción que sacudió al mundo Más allá de
los medios de masas convencionales Rosa
no se puede entender la idea que tenemos
sobre esta guerra sin tener en cuenta la
información que circula a través de las
redes sociales
[Música]
precisamente nos acompaña James Bridge
periodista del medio independiente ruso
Times para hablar de la importancia de
las redes sociales en la comunicación de
este conflicto Buenos días James
Entonces qué papel juegan las redes en
la guerra en Ucrania
Okay
creo que la manera en que se usan las
redes sociales en el conflicto de uso
ucraniano no tiene precedentes
lo digo porque lo hemos visto como nunca
antes en el sentido de que hay tanta
documentación en lugares como Twitter
Instagram
que sabemos mucho más sobre este
conflicto que sobre Las Guerras pasadas
y esto ha abierto la puerta a la crítica
sobre todo dentro de Rusia sobre cómo el
ejército está luchando esta guerra
porque la gente puede ver las pérdidas
humanas las pérdidas de tanques y esto
sin duda está generando ciertas
frustraciones en Moscú sí James y
centrémonos en Rusia y en Telegram Cuál
es el papel de esta plataforma dentro de
Rusia
hemos visto como Telegram en la invasión
rusa de Ucrania se ha usado de una forma
muy interesante tenemos que remontarnos
a cuando Rusia invadió Ucrania el 24 de
febrero exponencialmente lo que el
crimen hizo tras lanzar la invasión fue
intentar bloquear a la prensa
independiente y restringir la manera en
que se puede reportar la guerra dentro
de Rusia
lo que creó un vacío en el espacio
informativo ruso los rusos Simplemente
no podían acceder a lo que sucedía en
Ucrania
este vacío llegó al nacimiento de estos
grupos mayoritariamente de hombres que
son patrióticos y que apoyan al gobierno
y apoyan la decisión del gobierno de
invadido Ucrania
estos grupos tienen acceso a información
de lo que pasa en el terreno en Ucrania
y la reportan a sus decenas sino cientos
de miles de suscriptores en Telegram
esto ha generado preocupación en Rusia
porque esencialmente significa que la
gente tiene acceso información que no ha
sido filtrada por el estado pero también
significa que a medida que hemos visto a
Rusia sufrir retrocesos en el campo de
batalla los blogueros por guerra como se
les conoce han ido adoptando posturas
cada vez más críticas hacia el kremlin y
en la manera en que lucha esta guerra
claro James puede ser algo común entre
los jóvenes usar Telegram Pero qué hay
de las generaciones
mayores funcionan un poco distinto en
Rusia los que tienen digamos más de 50
años se informan de las noticias a
través de programas televisivos de
propaganda y medios estatales
enciendes la televisión Estatal rusa
cada noche encuentras tertulias sobre
temas como los nazis ucranianos o al
principio de la guerra se referían al
régimen de kievs como drogadictos
intentan influir la opinión de la gente
y que apoyan la guerra es una táctica
increíblemente Poderosa
por eso entre las generaciones jóvenes y
las mayores hay una gran diferencia en
lo que creen y en su actitud respecto a
esta guerra
si volvamos a los jóvenes aparte de
poder acceder a Telegram consiguen
esquivar la censura
al principio de la guerra del crimen Se
movió para echar a los medios
occidentales o a plataformas digitales
occidentales Así que censuraron cosas
como metas censuraron cosas como
Instagram
embargo esencialmente esto provocó una
búsqueda masiva para descargar vpns en
Rusia y poder continuar accediendo a
estas páginas y continuar accediendo a
noticias que no hayan tenido que pasar
por el estado para ser consumidas y para
terminar James las redes sociales han
servido o sirven para organizar a la
oposición contra la guerra también
[Música]
las redes sociales como Telegram se han
convertido en una plataforma muy útil
para los grupos de oposición por un lado
porque la app está encriptada y también
porque es una buena manera de reunir
gente anonimamente
hay un grupo que conocí el mes pasado
Que básicamente lleva a cabo sabotajes
ataques contra las vías de tren para
intentar evitar que Rusia pueda
transportar tanques y otros
equipamientos hacia Ucrania haciendo
explotar vagones de tren y la forma en
que se organizan estos grupos e intentan
informar es a través de Telegram donde
puedes seguir sus canales y ver su
trabajo
James Muchísimas gracias por compartir
su tiempo y su conocimiento con nosotros
Ah ya están en esta guerra dos bloques
luchan en el terreno Y en el espacio
mediático para encarrilar la historia de
acuerdo con su visión del mundo rosa si
Marta un conflicto ideológico imposible
de ganar por la fuerza llegamos así al
final de esta emisión a ustedes
Muchísimas gracias por su atención
[Música]